would it actually be such a disaster if
we didn't come up with the deal after
all we're here in the studio to mull
that over I'm joined by a Stephen Kelly
the chief executive the biggest tech
company in the UK footsie 100 software
giants sage and Richard Tye she's the
chairman of the campaign group leave
means leave as well as been chief
executive of the property investment
group quid Nick Capital Partners right
Richard let's keep her with you if we
didn't get a deal would it bother you no
wouldn't at all and Tim Martin was quite
right on his PC earlier the reality is
no deal is always better than a bad deal
and no one goes into business
negotiation saying we're going to take
two years to negotiate this if you put a
group of business people either side of
this table and said you've got two
months to negotiate this deal from this
summer it would be done and you then
give it to the lawyers and I believe
what the government should do they
should bring in some business expertise
and B they should set very clearly a
tight timeframe if we haven't agreed to
deal by q1 next year that's fine we walk
away as friends and we revert to WTO
everybody knows where they stand
all right Bob we got business expertise
tell us the talk Stephen Kelly I mean
first of all Stephen any chance in your
mind of a complete deal done by the end
of March 2019 yes huge a complex but as
Richard said I think if you had private
sector people working on both sides
actually you would have frame it where
you do the heads of agreement you get
the core principles established and then
the legals follow part of that might be
a transitional period so it's feasible
but boy it's ambitious and I think it's
really important to have an imperative
interestingly when I was in government
in the coalition government when there
was a head of steam and a real focus or
a burning platform things moved really
really quickly so it could be done but
is ambitious and I think to have some
experience around the table is an
imperative but but as you said if this
was a private sector initiative maybe
but it's not I mean there's 28 tables
around that 28 countries around that
table all with vested interests I think
Justin king said if you wanted a
negotiation this is about a bad a place
to start isn't it yeah I think I think
what we would call on behalf of small
and medium businesses across the UK is
that the politicians continue an
optimistic and positive narrative the
sentiments really important for the way
businesses feel
at the moment you know everybody's
worried about the sky falling in water
from June 23rd 24th reality is the only
major factories still had been devalued
on the one hand our customers are saying
import prices have gone up they passed
most of those on to the customers so
inflation is kicked in two to three
percent on the other side around table a
couple of weeks ago as customers were
saying for exporters they're filling
their boots they're all the book is
bulging so again I think the reality is
business people just carry on and get on
with it and there's always uncertainty
and we're in uncharted waters but they
just carry on on focus on their business
but that's why you got to change the
frame of the negotiation and you know
the framework of what's going on just in
King is right you know it's it's not the
right way to carry out a negotiation
that's why you've got to give people
much more certainty to say we're going
to tighten the timeframe you know bring
it much much shorter so everybody knows
where they stand because the worst thing
is is in an ongoing uncertainty even
though muscles and muscles you know
break sure you know that's not gonna
work in the real world you can't get a
deal in the real world honesty in the
real world it could absolutely happen
frankly by this autumn it's because the
politicians are going to play games that
just in Kingdom but you know others are
saying it's going to take too long
bring it in change the terms of the
debate and say look everybody should
plan for WTO WTO is fine okay a free
trade agreement with the EU is just the
cherry on the icing of the brexit cake
that we will have and we will eat all
the benefits from brexit don't come from
a free trade agreement they come from
controlling your own laws trade
agreements and borders and that's got
nothing to do with the free trade deal
that's a that's a fully loaded cake
we've got a listen on the ground it will
be delicious even half of the countries
half of the companies run this country
use sage software you must have a pretty
good sense of how they're feeling is
this uncertainty affecting them as much
as anything else to do with braces I
think yeah the reality is again we
forget there's always uncertainty about
ten years ago we could be sitting here
would be worrying about people at
Northern Rock going out of business so
there's always uncertainty and that was
uncharted waters with the financial
crisis we're into unchartered waters
here
it's amazing how resilient businesses
across Britain they really generally get
up every morning at five or six o'clock
and they worry about hiring people
taking on a prince
is looking after their customers
exporting and running their business and
the level of focus they have on running
their business and you just look about
the financial meltdown two-thirds of the
jobs of this country have been created
by small and medium businesses they just
got already carried on although men grow
richer as you would know plenty of
economists say the shockwave hasn't even
nearly heat us yet these are the same
economists that were part of project
fear that said you know the world was
going to collapse on June the 24th last
year they were almost all wrong with the
exception of economists for free trade
the reality is we've got over 250
occupiers of buildings around the
country that we manage in our business
and almost to a business they are busy
they're expanding you're working really
hard you know it's such a transparent
hard-working country and economy with
very good Indust relations I think I
think conditions are actually much
better than the doomsayers and the
economists believe student yeah yeah I
think I've been very critical part of
the doom says the naysayers I think the
narrative from the politicians
especially whoever gets elected on Judy
eighth has to be positive because
Britain have got fantastic entrepreneurs
and they carry on and they walk around I
think it's really important to focus on
that that every day they get up look at
expanding their business a lot of these
businesses have funded themselves or
borrowed from friends and family to
start their businesses and they've got
nowhere else to go and they're really
focused on particularly exporters
driving growth because of the cheaper
pound which is your key to children that
there's a really important here point
here which is that actually business
leaders and politicians have got to
infuse some confidence amongst the
public that actually WTO is fine
it is that's what most countries around
the world trade under you know most
people are not members countries are not
members of the European Union America
China Australia they trade with the EU
under WTO it's fine don't scare people
just a wonderful Steven you you watch
the devisor to the government I mean are
our executives inside the government up
to this job do you think I think you
know is a case where government and
private sectors work together we always
say keep a chair empty for the
entrepreneurs but let's get them in the
room I think the government was looking
at consultation with the private
later I would commend that and on the
other side of the EU exactly the same
because what we fear actually is we stop
the progress we've made on deregulation
on a much more fair tax environment and
allow the blockers that are get in the
way business being removed
we hope that the government just doesn't
become myopic on brixi and we want them
to really drive some of the deregulation
initiatives stoven Bridget thank you
both very much